[Music]
the work done by a cell is often not
visible to the human eye so to make it
more meaningful to us we can consider
the analogous work we might do as humans
so consider a bowl there lying at the
bottom of a hill we can imagine having
to exert a lot of energy to push that
Boulder to the top of the hill if we
then release the boulder at any point
before getting it all the way to the top
it will roll back downhill without
needing any help from us processes like
a boulder rolling down a hill that
happened without having to add any
additional effort or energy are called
spontaneous processes like pushing a
boulder up a hill that requires the
input of energy are called non
spontaneous many cellular processes are
spontaneous for example in the last
lesson we described how phospholipids
self-assemble into by layers when
dissolved in an aqueous solution such as
water or the cytosol we can now further
define this self-assembly as being a
spontaneous process on the other hand
when a cell has to perform a non
spontaneous process such as making a
protein it typically does so by
releasing the energy stored in a
molecule called ATP synthase used to
power so many cellular functions it is
vitally important for cell to be able to
produce large amounts of ATP with this
in mind let's examine one organelle in
particular the mitochondrion one of my
favorites as we mentioned briefly in the
last lesson the mitochondrion is the
functional module that allows cells to
maximize the amount of ATP that is
generated from the energy contained in
the food we and our cells consume
compartmentalization is crucial here
we're looking at a three dimensional
transmission e/m of a cell contrary to
the 2d representation that we usually
see the compartmentalization is clearer
and more evident the role of the
mitochondrion is quite specifically to
synthesize ATP each mitochondrion is
surrounded by a double membrane
structure made up of separate outer and
inner membranes the outer mitochondrial
membrane contains pouring channels
these are channels that allow ions and
most small molecules to diffuse into the
mitochondrion macromolecules such as
proteins and RNA molecules are way too
large to diffuse through the outer
membrane the outer membrane is also
extremely rich in enzymes associated
with mitochondrial lipid synthesis this
is critical for the division of
mitochondria indeed their reproduction
because to create more mitochondria you
need more membrane in contrast the inner
mitochondrial membrane is highly folded
into invaginations called cristae and it
surrounds the innermost compartment of
the mitochondrion called the matrix
cardiolipin is an abundant lipid in the
mitochondrial inner membrane however it
is not present in the mitochondrial
outer membrane which is primarily
composed of regular phospholipids
this helps to underscore just how
different those two membranes are unlike
the outer membrane the inner membrane is
highly impermeable to most small ions it
is composed of three major classes of
proteins that make up 76% of its mass
the first class of proteins are those
enzymes critical for catalyzing a subset
of reactions necessary for metabolism
the second class are transport proteins
that help move metabolites like pyruvate
from the inter membrane space into the
matrix of the mitochondria and the third
class are a highly specialized set of
enzyme complexes called
f1 f0 ATP a s that directly synthesizes
ATP given the relative difficulty of
moving molecules across the inner
mitochondrial membrane and into the
matrix specific transporter proteins are
required for moving small molecules and
ions across this membrane the
mitochondrion double membranes establish
two discrete and distinctive areas
within the organelle we saw that the
matrix is the volume enclosed by the
inner membrane making it the innermost
space within the mitochondrion while the
volume between the two membranes is
called the inter membrane
space the matrix contains hundreds of
enzymes involved in what's called the
citric acid cycle and it also contains
the mitochondrial DNA genome it is a far
more viscous environment compared to the
cytosol because it has a higher
concentration of soluble proteins it
plays a critical role in ATP synthesis
and in the process of so-called
oxidative phosphorylation the inter
membrane space has a similar consistency
as the cytosol
however the protein composition is very
different due to size selectivity of the
outer mitochondrial membrane there are
also proteins that are specifically
localized in the inter membrane space
cytochrome C is one such example of a
protein concentrated in this region
you
you
[Music]